very good evening to you now the big
thing you announced today or that you
call for today is an internet sales tax
how would it work there's very simple
just like v80 so whatever sales a
internet company make they have to pay a
20% tax and that would apply from abroad
or in the UK the only thing that would
prevent them from having to pay that the
20% on all their internet sales is if
they did at least 80% of their turnover
through traditional high street stores
so someone like sports director which is
probably on path like many other
retailers to end up doing 40% of its
sales online would have to think twice
now about closing stores or if not
reopening stores all going if you like
back into sort of smaller cities big
towns so we can keep our sales at 80
percent in the physical retail ie the
high stream now you said today to MPs
the high street is dead yeah at the
bottom of the swimming pool I think you
said yeah I mean so would this actually
bring some of these locations back to
life or is this just about saving what
we've gotten there
III think the high street is actually in
a bit of a death spiral at the moment so
the most important thing is before we
even worry about saving the person on
the bottom of a swimming pool who has
died is let's stop the another couple
falling in and see if we can save then
that's how I would look at the problem
what about some of these pure pay
internet retailers the lights of boohoo
common yeah Amazon I mean this is
they're gonna scream blue murder of this
yeah they are and but they they have to
accept they have to level up the playing
field because in the end it isn't a
level playing field even though I'm
poacher gamekeeper on both sides of this
now I can understand it from the
internet side they will hate this but
they will adjust they will maybe open up
the physical stalls they will open up
stalls that were taking in in their
local high streets you can actually go
and deliver click and Collect and that
counts towards their retail turnover so
that helps them to get to the 80% have
you heard from any other retailers about
I mean people like Justin King the
former sayings for his bosses also
called for an online sales tax have you
have you heard back from
people saying good on you for saying
this yes but I was he don't want to name
names but I agree with people like
Justin King we need to do something and
we need to do it now
it's no good debating it for three years
because all the time that the high
streets that were above average all of a
sudden before below average all of a
sudden and I'm not naming names but for
whatever reason over MLS or a debenhams
pull out of that high street it all but
kills it and then an SD thinks well if
they're not going to be here maybe we
don't renew our lease and maybe we start
moving out and then there's not a lot
anybody can do I just believe we ought
to act now even if it's not but in the
very short term in s these groups
benefit and what about House of Fraser
which you thought you said all fifty
nine stores com feasibly stay open
realistically yeah what's the ideal
number of stores for that group probably
a lot less than the 80 percent that I
promised from a financial thing but
we're trying to look past the very short
term a House of Fraser we believe
hopefully things will happen to save the
high street so if I actually did it or
financial I would like my wood I can
guarantee you over half them would have
to close so there's only so much we can
do before we have everybody has to dig
in and help so that's that's the way I
look at it now you told the MPs today
you'd like to see House of Fraser
working much more closely with Debenhams
in which you own 27% you've written a
value of your stake down to zero what
your ultimate ambition with Deb's o
ultimate ambition it's a if it's a bit
like a moving feast what we really would
have liked because I didn't think I
would be owning House of Fraser I had an
alum percent stake in it I didn't think
I'd end up being the owner what I did
think is that we were plus/minus try and
do with Debenhams what would we're going
to do with House of Fraser and that's
basically give people the right product
at the right time at the right price it
sounds very simple but you need a
healthy high street to be able to do
that so I think debenhams has gotten at
solutely almighty tasks I'm happy to
work with them I'm happy to discuss
things I'm happy to see if there's any
synergies where we can work together but
that is a very very tough ask they've
got with their historic rental
agreements that basically the current
management with nothing to do with well
obviously the way around that for Deb's
is either a company voluntary agreement
in the worst case scenario going into
administration I mean would you be
interested in buying Deb's if it went
into administration I look at all things
so to me I would say yes yes by the way
I do think there ones needs to do a CVA
because the the rents are wrong you know
I don't care who's running debenhams
these wrong rents that were set in 2006
seven whenever they were they're
probably fifty percent above what they
would have to pay in the market now I'm
an interesting thing when you bought
House of Fraser I mean you paid ninety
million pounds for the business that was
largely for the stock you've just paid
ninety five million for one freehold up
in Glasgow I mean yeah you clearly
perceive value in the estate yes no
there are there are with the House of
Fraser stalls there are some absolutely
that some of them are just incredible so
you will get like anything a minority
that are just there just in the league
of their own but people aren't talking
about that the few they're talking about
the many now the many are going to need
a lot of help but the logical conclusion
of what you just said is that ultimately
House of Fraser and Debenhams could
merge yeah that they could merge it and
in my opinion they should at least work
very closely together because they
should think of that all the
distribution cost savings think of how
they need to work together with each
other you know there's all sorts of
things they could buy together then on
the shipment cost product from the Far
East they could share Freight they could
get best practices they could make a
difference if they work together as a
lot of businesses on the high street
we'll have to get used to not just
apartments thoughts and how do you read
the commercial property sector more
widely at the moment I mean you're it's
interesting with you having bought House
of Fraser you're playing hardball with a
lot of the landlords and none of them
are agreeing to renegotiate rents with
you others like in to have said no yeah
well I think Hindi you simply can't they
win the win the battle and they lose the
war because they have to understand it's
not that we don't want to pay the rents
the rents are now at the wrong levels
that the home market is shifted
downwards and I tried to explain this
today in Bond Street the rents are still
going up in Oxford Street the rents are
still going up that doesn't help me if
I'm in Middlesbrough in Middlesbrough
the rents are plummeting
so therefore the level of rink currently
being paid in Middlesbrough is not
realistic the system was basically built
on a premise that everything would
gradually go up up put only rent reviews
all the other things they have and in
this day and age that is not realistic
the world has changed what about some of
the other big boys are the commercial
property set to the hammer scens the
land sex the British lands of this world
are they be more pragmatic than nur than
in - yes that they have been that
doesn't mean we've been able to do deals
but at least we're a lot closer and what
they crave is information what they want
to understand is are you just trying to
get a cheap rent because you're
profiteering or do we really need to
lower these rents do we really need to
work with you on turnovers and by the
way who's gonna invest in the stores I
said today a store 100,000 square feet
if it's 150 pound a square foot shop fit
that's 15 million to refit those house
appraisers doors when they're borderline
making money there isn't a very
realistic prospect so some of those
landlords are gonna go right if you're
going to sum up long lease you're gonna
put Sports Direct guarantee in it we're
gonna join you and where they're
essentially going to invest with me to
see if we can hit that business some
longevity well of looking at Sports
Direct the backbone of your empire when
you started it was a pure retail
business online came along in due course
I mean if you were starting out again
today with a multi-platform
multi-channel business how many stores
and Sports Direct will you realistically
have about 50 in the UK and that's all
yeah crikey yeah and where do you think
I mean a lot of people say that Sports
Direct it's it's been overtaken by JD
innocent years where did it go wrong I
mean for
for many many years you were the market
leader well what happened well I don't
think so much sports director went wrong
I think it's a it's a the similar to the
flannels flannels it's actually the
consumers habits of chains they've all
gone very branded so ten years ago
people would would rather have a couple
of P K's than one expensive branded one
now with the phones and the pressure and
the internet and all the social media
people are going branded so we have this
flannels business which is actually
above JD which is actually define all
the high street that want one of our
words it's on fire
but that doesn't mean sports the
reckless doing anything wrong that's
just the way the consumers are going and
that's why we have to elevate Sports
Direct I mean obviously you and lots of
brands that you sell through sports
direct their asset Dunlop Slazenger
internet for thought are there any
brands missing in the portfolio I mean
what would you love to have in there
that that you don't turn right now
besides Nike but no namibian silly now
there's always lots of brands that you
would wish to own hack it for example
nice UK brand heritage that sort of one
it's all about elevation so all you've
got to do is it's a bit like what was
good enough ten years ago simply isn't
good enough today and the consumers are
demanding more what about French
Connection UN 27% of that you know
founder Steve marks has put up for sale
is that something you're interested in
not not particularly because I actually
believe Stephen marks is the secret
sauce behind French Connection so for me
I'm very happy with him in it
I wouldn't be trying to take him out of
it if I can put it like that
and what about more January I mean what
would you love to own in terms of assets
if there was anything that was available
and in terms of retail assets what would
you love to have Selfridges Selfridges
well there you go I mean no no doubt the
Western family are watching so no no no
no I can't afford it let's be crystal
clear yeah and what about how do you
read the consumer right now I mean the
consumer confidence figures out today
we're back to where we were after the
referendum this is a very very bad bad
time to be going into the the golden
quarter yeah it's very very tough on the
high street if I'm not doing directly
about the Sports Direct Group but
essentially if you've had a five-year
trend you've had the
tell high street down 1% down 3% down 3%
down 4% currently down 5% you know next
year's gonna be even worse and it's
gonna be down 6% so that's why I say
people if they have to act they really
will have to knock the cover off the
ball and really make something happen
you said it would be a good luxury
Christmas good for the luxury retailers
yeah what about the likes of Amazon
though I mean if your tax comes in yeah
you think you could see Amazon going
into physical retail oh I could I can't
guarantee it but you could you can rest
assured they wouldn't want to pay that
20% tax and they would soon work out how
to drive people back into the high
street